welcome back to Las Vegas now Lotus of
Siam is a staple in the Las Vegas
community and they are set to open their
third location in Red Rock Casino and
joining us with a preview of the menu we
have owners chef safian churma and Penny
churma thank you guys so much for being
here so I love Lotus of Siam and I love
Red Rock so I am so excited for you guys
how does it feel to be opening this new
location and joining the Summerlin and
Red Rock Family
exhilarating anxiety obviously you know
it's one of those things where I don't
think anyone's ever ever going to be
prepared for it well you guys are taking
over the city and I have just been
standing here smelling how amazing this
smells your guys's food is absolutely
delicious tell us about some of the
items we have in front of us here and
that will be on the menu at Red Rock So
currently we have the garlic prawns
which is our staple dish we also have
the Thai style steak tartar
it sounds amazing garlic prawns just so
everybody knows the shell is edible it's
deep fried to a crisp it's like we
always compare it to kind of like a
garlic potato I can smell the garlic
it's delicious and Penny you know you
guys are a family-run business it's so
important to you how does it feel to be
joining the Summerlin family and the
community and just sharing the Lotus of
Siam love hello
excited you know and it's one of the
things that you know we try to grow
organically we don't want to force the
growth so I feel like at this point
we're a little bit there to be able to
open in Summerlin oh you are fully there
and I think it's incredible to welcome
people into the Thai Community I have
visited Thailand before and I know just
the food the people the community
everything there is so special and we're
lucky to have you guys out here in Las
Vegas so you guys are opening soon you
get the key soon you don't have an
actual date but Lotus Asylum will be at
Red Rock before we know it right all
right well thank you guys for joining us
I can't wait to come in and try it how
do you say thank you in Thai
thank you guys all right Rocky I will
send it over to you I love